but this is becoming and computer  doesn't like it Knight C3 Knight C3  oh my God explode oh  wait you're not saying he's dead  well he needs a miracle to survive  but why isn't he dead  how is he surviving cars  I don't get it I mean Knight takes E4 is  a brutal threat there is a pin is he  just taking on G4  wow but I mean okay look look at Magnus  no but again right Magnus blundering  things he usually doesn't blunder  and we're being told by sateras yes our  producer shout out to him like yes  Bishop takes G4 is mandatory he's not  dead but it is bad for white I'm sorry  for black and Bishop takes G4 on the  board only move not to resign but the  game has turned on its head it's up to  satorial with the advantage